thrilled to have here on the show really
enjoyed his work with brian griese and
steve levy in the booth for monday night
football
and uh he talks ball all the time for
the worldwide leader in sports lewis
riddick here on the show how are you
lewis
rich i'm good man i appreciate you uh
having me on no thank you for for coming
on
this program right now uh i uh let's
let's just jump
right into it um with uh what's going on
with desean watson i mean you know you
know how
front office's approach matters um and
it's always like let's stick with plan a
until
plan b somebody walks through the door
with an offer that we can't refuse but
it does not even seem like it it looks
like the
the texans are even refusing to
acknowledge there's a a door b
right now what do you think is going on
with this lewis yeah
i think when you think about i think
nick casario's
you know he was looking at this going
look this is my first time being a gm
i have the final say do i really want to
be known as the guy who at the
first crack of being a gm after knocking
on the door so many different times and
for different reasons not being able to
you know i actually finished the deal do
i want to be known as the guy who traded
deshaun watson
that's the first thing that he did he
traded one of the most dynamic
quarterbacks that quite honestly
when you look at him play for play stat
for stat
he's right up there with some of the
greats that are playing this game right
now mainly the guy who everybody
considers to be the standard
patrick mahomes do you want to be known
as that guy
and i think but once you get past that
when you look
at the long game rich i think and i've
said this numerous different times
if i got to a point where i could get to
a face to face with desean
and he was telling me this and i really
did for all intents and purposes believe
him
when he said i'm not playing for you
because this isn't even about you this
isn't
my my problem isn't with you my problem
goes way above you
then i would really start saying hey
look it's time for us to start picking
up the phone because
i need to build this football team i
need to do what's in the best interest
of this team
both now and in the future we need the
pics we need the capital
and there's some people out there right
now that are just flat out desperate
for for this guy and we might be able to
take them
straight to the cleaners you have to
start considering that and i think right
now
honestly god if i was in that chair
i would be considering it i really would
i mean you have to right i mean because
it does appear that it does appear that
he's
he's he's communicated everything that
you say you you would need to hear
sitting in that chair and and you know i
was mentioning before on the show and
you know um
you you may have heard uh uh you know
certainly through
uh our friend greenie as well i i suffer
from the same affliction as as greeny
um with the jets and this has nothing to
do with that
if you're in that position uh where
you've got a player saying this to your
face
wouldn't you want not one but two teams
that have
top three draft choices and multiple
first rounders that they would be
potentially uh willing to give but
because they
have them and also 23 year old
quarterbacks that can also be flipped
to you in the trade and even better to
play them off each other
they're division rivals i mean this is
this is the mother lode
that you'd want to have created now the
only issue that you would
maybe make it wish for you to be better
is that it would be in another
conference
so you don't have to see this kid once
every but once every four years
uh you know what i'm saying like it
seems to be perfect yeah there's a
couple scenarios that are like that i
mean
really even though carolina's not in the
division yes
correct you know there's still another
one where okay would you
would you be willing to survive do you
think you could survive short term with
a guy like teddy bridgewater plus
all the draft capital that you can get
plus whatever
other player that they'd be willing to
give you off of that roster considering
that right now
they're basically telling you just look
at what we have and tell us what you
want i mean that's really what teams are
doing right now
for you know in terms of their making an
attempt to see if this is really
something that they can consummate
and i think this too rich the longer
this goes and i've had a couple of
people tell me this
we can't the meaning from the from the
team side from the potential acquiring
team side we can't wait forever
we can't deal in in hypotheticals and
wishing that and hoping that eventually
either he or russell comes available
the longer this goes the more we have to
go to our plan b
c and d especially in the quarterback in
the quarterback situation
and that's just and and at some point in
time we have to close off the door to
this
we can't revisit it we can't go into the
draft like let's just say this drives
all the way up to the draft
or even past the draft they draft the
quarterback and then all of a sudden
houston goes hey you know what
yeah we are going to trade him t i mean
what are you going to do you're not
going to trade for deshaun watson if you
just
drafted a quarterback in the first round
or just gave someone a contract that
locks you into some things from a salary
cap planning perspective
and then just blow it all up because
then they decide so i think it's also
important for houston to time this up
right too
because i'm talking they could clean i'm
just telling you they could and you know
this i mean this isn't hard to figure
out you could clean up in this situation
clean up and for and for nick
look if he's having these conversations
with kyle mcnair right now look
nick if i'm nick i'm sitting back in my
chair going i didn't create this
yeah i didn't i didn't really you say
that to the new boss
you know what i'm i'm saying you know
what i guess i'm saying that to myself
right you know i'm saying at one point
look yeah
you know i'm sure you know we're in this
together but in the back of my mind i'm
thinking
look i'm trying to build this football
team i'd love to build this football
team with about four extra first and
seconds
plus a quarterback who i think i can win
with and
you know some nice cap space going
forward i i'd like that situation
i wouldn't want to take the short-term
hit of being the guy that traded deshaun
watson
but in my mind what would give me some
well besides the fact that i signed i
don't know what is next on a five
six-year deal i mean i was along with
that security i'd be thinking
i'm trying to build this going forward
so either way you know i think i'm good
and
i just think that they have to start
looking along those lines and thinking
along those lines
and i really would and i'm not just
saying this because i'm not in that
chair
i'm saying it because i really do
believe
if i felt that desean was dug in like he
is and he's given nobody any reason to
think otherwise
i think timing is everything in this and
i think it's on their side right now but
for with every passing day
i think that could start changing i
agree louis uh lewis riddick here on the
rich eisen show because
look you know being on this side
of the business right now with a
microphone attached to your
lapel or wearing a headset you know
you know that with each passing day that
the texans don't make this maneuver
there's at least
i could probably name 10 people in your
shop alone that would love to have that
one-on-one with desean watson
there's me there's 10 people in my shop
there's 10 people in fox's shop
i mean honestly and all he's got to do
is choose one
and then suddenly the leverage goes out
the window that they have
when he says the words publicly into a
microphone sitting in a one-on-one chair
or tweets it out if he wants to put it
make his own content his own because
that's the way things go
changes the dynamic in 10 seconds 10
seconds
because right now you've got in carolina
an owner
in david tepper who wants to make the
biggest splash possible and you got two
teams potentially
in the afc east worried that the other
one might actually pull off the deal
and you got you got this all played out
and it's wired
and nobody has fallen head over heels in
love yet with somebody for a second or
third overall pick
in new york or miami yet but that may
happen you know like so
this is it now's the time yeah and you
know what and
let's just throw another team in there
sure although they don't have
they can't offer the quarterback in
return
that a carolina can or a jet or the jet
can or miami can
and i keep saying this and and i know
that the people you know
who work there i mean some of them are
good friends of mine they're probably
going lewis why are you doing this to us
but they know it too in chicago
they are in a tough tough spot
okay if they don't swing and i mean like
barry bonds knock it out of the park
swing and hit
at quarterback they are in a tough spot
because then they're sitting there at
the 20 spot in the first round
and they got to get up ahead of teams
that potentially want to drop the
quarterback like the patriots
maybe the 49ers the broncos
carolina's sitting there hungry for a
quarterback maybe the eagles
falcons dolphins jet jaguar what are
they going to do then
they said yesterday well you know what
we haven't closed the door i'm bringing
back mr pinsky mr biscuit yeah
right you're not going down that road
you have nick poles under contract
that's not going to work
what are you going to trade for marcus
mariota no that's not going to work
you're going to sign ryan fitzpatrick no
you're going to sign james now you're
going to sign alex smith
especially not when both the gm and the
head coaches jobs
are on the line here in 2021 that's
another team that when you sit i mean
i'm telling i bet if they picked up the
phone in houston
they would say what do you want just
tell us who do you want
what khalil mack you want roquan smith
you won our next three first
three first round pitch what do you want
that's what i'm saying like it's really
one of those i i don't know
let's just say this drags out into the
season let's say deshawn decides hey
i'll miss a game
i'll miss a couple games i'm not gonna
blink where does that leave you
what have you shown what have you proven
by saying i don't want to establish the
precedent of having
quarterbacks being able to walk into our
office and say i don't want to play for
you
and then all of a sudden we're just kind
of caving to that pressure i don't want
to establish that precedent i don't want
other
players coming in doing that you're not
proving anything here i mean
you're just you're cutting off your nose
despite your face here in this situation
yeah exactly what you're doing no doubt
i mean you are
uh spitting truth here louis i mean and
and
and uh honestly um
the one thing we haven't mentioned
throughout this entire conversation
because we could sit here and say
absolutely jets absolutely carolina
absolutely miami
absolutely chicago you could throw you
know san francisco into the mix
potentially or anybody wants to swing
for a fence as you said
right you could do all that desean's got
a no trade
clause on top of it he could shut it
down
yep at any moment so there's
you've got to be on the same page with
somebody who wants to not even be in
your book
anymore it's insane in each passing day
to try and get it done
with a draft approaching if it's the
week of imagine pulling something like
this off on a draft night
i mean that would be insanity that would
be it would
insane to do that it would be good for
us
it'd be good for you good for us to be
good for everybody and
you know what i i'll tell you secretly
i'm hoping something like that does
happen
but but but you're but you're right i
mean it's just uh
you know you just touched on something
though right
they have to still ironically
communicate with the guy
who could just blow up all their they
could they could do all this leg work
pick up the phone pass out all these
deals just
absolutely just go fantasy football hog
wild on this whole thing and get
everything's lined up and desean could
say nope
that's right i don't like that place and
you know what that comes down to again
the same thing that got him into this
mess communication
that's all this came down to let me see
people now think that this is just the
era of the prima donna quarterback and
all of a sudden guys are more selfish
now
and want to just do their own thing and
quarterbacks rich you know they've been
doing this for a long time
quarterbacks have been trying to dictate
their own destiny for a long time
since way back but we just kind of
selectively get kicked off about certain
things because of the optics and how it
looks
and it's almost like here you know now
people are saying well desean and
russell
they want to be gm's too they want to
pick coaches
and from my understanding and i think i
have a pretty good understanding and i'm
sure you do too that's not what he
wanted
he didn't start this people came to him
asked him about his input about certain
things he thought that was going to
continue going forward
he expressed some concerns about certain
things and then all of a sudden when the
rubber meets the road as mike common
likes to say
things changed on him you know i don't
care what business you're in
and i don't care what era it is you tell
somebody something like that
and you back out on your word
you're gonna get what's coming to you
and in this case it's a kid who says
i'm done just get me out of here send me
somewhere else and that that's too and
that's simply because
you didn't keep the main thing the main
thing you didn't keep your word
and that's got to account for something
at some point especially when you're
talking about a quarterback who you know
you know without him last year
you're lucky if you win those four games
you may win one
you know what i mean so it's it's just
kind of wild so sometimes you know we
make this stuff
so difficult and it's and it's really
it's really not i mean it's in terms of
communicating anyway i mean winning
football games in the nfl is hard but
communicating with your best players and
players who you have decided you want to
invest
the kind of money in them that you're
investing
it's not that hard to stay true to them
and stay open with them and stay honest
with them
and just let them know because that's
what players ultimately want they just
want you to stay true to what you're
saying
or don't say anything you know i mean if
there if you didn't want him to be
involved
you didn't want his input then you
should have never asked him
but don't put it out there and then take
it back and then expect there to be no
consequences for it i mean that's the
kind of stuff that just drives me up a
wall
just about business and life in general
don't put it out there and then pull it
back and then expect somebody to just
kind of just keep rolling because
you're the boss and they're the employee
i mean that's not the way it works
anymore
it really doesn't and i don't think it
should work that way louis riddick here
on the rich eisen show last one for your
louis before you i send you
uh back into your espn day there's so
many different quarterback and so many
different situations to talk about right
now and i'd love to have you back on as
the new league year begins when we get
closer to the draft
uh but uh but uh tj jefferson say hello
to lewis riddick go ahead say
say hello to lewis lewis riddick what up
man okay that's my social media
that's my social media grand maester uh
who's a diehard dallas cowboy fan who
doesn't want to hear about
dak prescott until the deal is done so
let me ask you about dak prescott and
what's going on with the dallas cowboys
lewis
what is going on there do you think talk
to me luke yeah you know
look this again see sometimes you know
what i just said sometimes it's not
it shouldn't be so hard i don't i don't
understand why this is so hard
and and i wish i knew everything about
the negotiation here
so you could really kind of pinpoint
what has happened
but let's just say that knowing what we
do know
we know this when teams want to make
deals they make deals and team when they
wanted to get patrick mahone signing
kansas city they got it done
yes heck when the texans wanted to get
desean done they got it done
it just got done why what is the what's
the holdup
who is who's the guy who's holding this
deal up because we
we we're not going to really argue about
just how good that is and
whether situationally he's a guy who can
make people better blah blah blah we saw
that earlier this year
dak is a fantastic quarterback i don't
know what the hold up is i don't know if
it's back representatives
in terms of the length of the contract
if jerry's uncomfortable
paying him 39 touching on 40 million per
year i don't know
but we saw what happened when he wasn't
on that football team
we saw how it cratered and right now
that you know look that's going to win
regardless
that's going to win if they franchise
them again i mean we but we'd all take
70 million over two years in cold hard
cash
that's what he gets don't sign him
that's fine too i hit the free agent
market and right now you know edward is
important that zach is on track to be
ready to go by this spring
yeah he's going to cash in and if you
franchise him and don't sign him to a
long-term deal and somehow he winds up
signing that tender next year he hits
the market
tv money's going to explode sorry cap's
going to go back up he's going to win
anyway
so dallas better i don't know what
they're doing but that's winning
that's all i know he's getting back he's
winning he's getting paid like kirk
cousins and garrett cole
combined from two sports they can all
guarantee it's unbelievable
you know and here's the last thing i'll
say rick i want to think about you know
the only thing i'll say about that this
is what they got to be careful about
okay
okay they're sending a message to their
players and to
the owners are sending messages to
players around the league when you do
this kind of thing
zach is a fourth round pick who did
everything right
since he's been there every single thing
right on the field
off the field elevated the people around
him
everything you ask and now all of a
sudden
you can't get him signed to a long-term
deal there's speculation that
because russell said that dallas is one
of the places that he'd like to play
can you imagine if they traded for
russell wilson didn't pay back
and brought someone else in there what
do you think that the players in that
locker room would say
and what do you think other you know
what do you think it would do to the
morale of that football team as far as
how they would look at
and these guys don't care about what you
do for this place this is just a cold
hard business and we know it's a
business but you know how that can
affect
how you acquire other players and
players wanting to come there
players like to be wanted and like to be
like to know that they're going to be
treated right what did jj just do
going to arizona what did he love about
that besides the money
he loved how they treated him how they
quoted it how they made him feel like he
was wanted
you don't better be careful when you
start treating guys like that
treating them like they're just
commodities dallas better be careful
lewis great chat really enjoyed it look
for my number please we'll keep calling
thank you for taking us going thanks a
lot rick right back at you at
l riddick espn i follow him you should
too at louis dot riddick on instagram
for monday night football wow that was
just great hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here